hello everyone and welcome to another
really fine game uh from the uh round
three of the uh
grand swiss currently being played in
riga latvia uh the uh organized by
fidence.com it's uh vasiv durabili of
azerbaijan versus the new lube of russia
it's quite a game so let's check it out
and see then we're gonna show the
standings a little bit uh so the rabbi
with the white pieces opens with e4 we
have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 so the real lopez is on the
board we have a6 morpheus defense and
bishop to a4 uh knight to f6 and now we
don't have the usual stuff like castles
d3 or whatnot we have the immediate d4
this is the mckenzie variation and it is
somewhat uh rarer in in top tier play so
we have e captures on d4 and now castles
why i can always pick up this pawn so
it's not really uh
he's not really in a hurry bishop to e7
and now e5 challenging this knight and
you have to be very very careful here so
here knight to e4 and now only now
knight captures on d4 and now usually
the game could continue with something
like captures captures then we play
knight to c5 attack the bishop then
bishop goes back to b3 and so on so this
is also very popular but in the game
blue of just castles and now we have
knight to f5 going after the bishop on
e7 and you also have to be very careful
because well ideas like queen to g4
might be coming bishop to h6 might be
might be coming in some lines so it's
best to just open up the position with
the d5 and this is a move you often have
to play either d6 or d5 whether it's the
italian some gioco piano or uh in this
sort of an open line of the rue lopez so
d5 we have to open our light square
bishop and now uh e knight captures any
on e7 you could also play captures on d6
alpha with something like bishop
captures an f5 captures on e7 queen
captures and then just pick up the pawn
here uh the the bishop and double black
spawns here and the material is equal
but you've messed up black spawn
structure somewhat but you've really
disregarded your own development uh so
maybe a white can do white can do better
so instead we have knight characters on
e7 with check knight captures now there
will be no doubling of the pawns here
and c3
uh so what what do you play now well
knight to c5 we challenge the bishop
here bishop back to c2 and now bishop to
f5 and you can see that black really has
no problems playing this variation uh he
neutralized all of white's ideas white
still has some issues developing the
piece not issues but he completely
disregarded development and you are now
attacking white's only developed piece
so here knight to a3 white needs to
continue developing pieces and now queen
d7 connecting rooks developing the queen
with bishop to e3 as the knight here is
unguarded and knight to e6 now
and the the position has been reached
before it's been reached uh in 2018 in
in croatia in the hula memorial
tournament between uh robert zeltz and
yada and koplancha where queen the h5
was played that game ended in a draw but
here we have f4 by doorbelly and now it
is as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game
so how do you continue here well it's a
tricky position and uh black black
should be uh careful about what he's
doing as you always should be uh one
move that comes to mind is something
like c5 and it really looks like
something you want to play then maybe
you push d4 next and so on but it is
very dangerous because white has this g4
move and now if you go to g6 then f5
just wins so you're going to have to
capture here and after some like knight
captures yes you can play d4 but now uh
f5 and well it's just very very
difficult to decide what's happening
here for example queen d5 uh we can't
capture the bishop here because the
queen would be hanging so we have to
play queen d5 the queen is now defended
on d5 and after something like captures
captures and bishop captures we're going
to play knight captures and queen
captures white will be up upon uh is it
enough for white well it's uh you know
uh it's it it's okay it's not not really
a problem uh so black definitely needs
to do better so instead of something
like c5 double finds the the critical f6
move and it's a it's a fine idea because
now
uh you can't really go for g4 because
now after g4 and the bishop captures on
c2 uh knight characters and c2 you have
this f5 move and this would not be
possible in that line where c5 was
played at g4 in bishop captures because
if f5 was played right away not first f6
f5 then white would have e captures on
f6 alpha
which would be very good for white but
here white doesn't have that so he would
have to play some like g5 and then c5
and it's a completely different story
now
so that's why uh f6 is such a tricky
move so uh the rabbi lee captures an f6
we have rook captures on f6 uh and now
queen to d2 he has to get the other rook
into the game uh we have rook 8 to f8
doubling up on the f file and now rook 8
to d1 and here duval says all right my
rooks are nicely placed my bishop is
well either capturing here or yours is
capturing here i'm just going to start
pushing h5 of course he wants to play h4
h3 and start an attack against white's
king
and what do you play here well you
should uh play something like b4 or you
should play something like bishop to b3
put more pressure on that the d5 pawn
where if maybe black defends it with c6
you can further undermine it with
something like c4 but here white played
bishop captures on f4 and it seems like
a
move that gives duba
a little bit too much because uh uh or
or or this was a blunder i don't know
because black doesn't have to capture
with the rook it seems like he does
because knight captures uh leaves
control of the d5 square uh but uh
that's exactly what dubo does he plays
knight captures on f5 and now the
problem is you don't have this capture
because the bishop on e3
would be hanging so here we have knight
to c2 now the bishop is defended and
we're ready to capture but now c6 and it
seems like the absence of the light
square bishops only favors uh
black because black has two knights and
this dark square bishop isn't really
doing all that much uh so here bishop
back to f2 and now comes knight to d6 so
the e4 square is available for the
knight and it's a light square white
will not be able to kick the knight away
from there so knight to d6 uh you're
either going to
e4 or c4 that's also an option so bishop
to g3 now adding another defender to the
f4 pawn and now not knight to the e4 but
knight to c4 you want to force white to
defend this lonely b2 pawn and uh as
this pawn is um on b2 unguarded if it
was for example on b4 then this wouldn't
really come with tempo so here we have
queen to c1 defending this pawn but it
doesn't matter because the position is
winning for black but you have to play
one uh particular move in order to gain
this winning advantage so feel free to
pause the video here and find the
winning idea for adubov while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course rook captures an f4 that is a
joke i'm only tricking you because it's
a weekend the move is of course h4
that's the move you had to find so
congratulations on finding it
um
and you know so sorry about tricking you
again uh here
uh it's uh uh it's simply a matter of
removing the defender of the uh f4 pawn
and there really isn't uh a good way to
counter this uh one idea is to push f5
this is possible but then if h captures
on g3 f captures an e6 we have this g
captures an h2 check and after king
captures now comes queen captures an e6
and there's no good way for white to
play this uh
whatever you do for example rook dt-1
you attack the queen we can just trade
here captures captures and now after
captures and captures uh you can play
knight captures on b2 you're up to pawns
of course completely winning so uh f5
although possible doesn't really do
anything so here white accepts this
challenge bishop captures on h4 but now
dubo just goes knight captures on f4 he
says i don't care about the
rook here you are more than welcome to
capture it but capturing the rook here
would be a bit too much because 92 check
just picks up the queen so of course
we're not going to play that
so instead we have rook to f2 guarding
the e2 square but now queen to g4 and it
seems like it's impossible to block
everything now the threat of just knight
to h3 check
is deadly and there is not all that much
you can do about it plus the bishop is
hanging here so bishop captures on f6 is
played but now knight the h3 with check
so it doesn't matter where you're going
king to h1 it's just bad so king to f1
is a bit more resilient knight captures
on f2 now attacking the this rook also
the bishop is still here uh hanging on
f6 so king captures and now rook
captures with check we have king to g1
and now uh queen to e2 with some very
simple ideas of
just rook f2 followed by rook captures
on g2 so rook to e1
uh attacking the queen but it doesn't
help queen f2 check king to h1 and now
the cheekiest move of the game at knight
captures on b to do justice i'm gonna
pick up a pawn there since you left it
there on b2 you did not play b4 at any
point in the game it's a free pawn and
if you capture it of course i can just
give up my queen for a very nice
checkmate here so white
sees that there are some background
issues he plays h3 but now rook to g6
attacking the g2 pawn and again doesn't
matter if you play rook to g1 it's a
simple matter of knight to d3 attacking
the queen and there is no good square
for the queen here for example if queen
to d1 whatever just queen to g3 now
threatening all sorts of nasty stuff for
example knight to f2 is the threat of
checkmate the only way to defend this is
the uh block with the queen somehow but
then of course we still deliver check
and win the queen so not much happening
there so after rook the g6 g4 was played
but now queen f3 check king to h2 and
the rook h6 and he was in this position
on move 34 that was dora bailey uh
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the uh
mate is being threatened whatever white
plays it's a mate in two unless you play
something really silly just to prolong
the game but let's say rookie three row
captures king g1 rook to h1 will be
checkmate
uh so a very nice game by duba uh it was
a pretty close a close game but um uh
right here at the this moment where uh
white decided to trade the the light
square bishops uh it seems like it was
uh too important of a tempo to to allow
black to just uh you know allow this
knight here to come to f5 because if
rook has the capture then it's not as
dangerous but the dubo just uh you know
maybe white completely overlooked this
that the queen cannot capture on d5
although it seems very unlikely for
such a strong player to overlook
something like this but you know it's
possible so who knows what was the idea
there
uh but yeah once again that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it we're gonna
check out the standings after three
rounds round four has already started so
we're going to enjoy some games from
that uh but here are the standings after
uh
the the first three rounds so if you
only player on three out of three then
we have six players and two and a half
out of three you young yi paul poncratov
nihal sarin even charity chief guinea
and robert
uh followed by uh like 20 people with
two points uh the top players being
fabiano quran anton korobo and vincent
keimer
uh so yeah those were the standings hope
you enjoyed that as well uh and yeah i
would like to thank derek king thc
ali.nl george knows where the uh abdel
el traure and david kimura for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
magnificent event uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh so thank
you i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your weekend